now ironically at this time of
presidential candidates being separated
from reality we've got a new entrance
into the race kanye west is running for
president you got to tell you I read
through his very long interview that he
just gave to Forbes I kind of like
candidate Kanye I I know it sounds I am
pre-pro Kanye I'm gonna vote for Trump
I'm not gonna vote for Kanye in 2020 but
I got to tell you Kanye has a lot of
good things to say politically here's
just the top line from the interview he
says he's running for president in 2020
under a new banner the birthday party
that's the name of his political party
the birthday party with guidance from
Elon Musk and an obscure vice
presidential candidate he's already
chosen the vice presidential candidate
is just a preacher I think from the
Midwest love that oh yeah are you
telling me you could pick either like
some random congressman some some empty
suit sociopath like most people choose
for running mates or political
appointments or just a good old preacher
from the heartland of America sign me up
man I'm with Kanye he says that he's
okay with siphoning off black votes from
the Democratic nominee thus helping
Trump he says I'm not denying it I just
told you to say that the black vote is
democratic as a form of racism and white
supremacy damn right it is absolutely
the way that they're taught you you see
this constantly people attacking Kanye
because he's stealing votes
he's stealing black votes from Joe Biden
meaning Joe Biden owns those black
voters Debra Messing the actress said
this just the other day said it's too
absolutely disgusting she said quote
he's playing Jill Stein he's trying to
take young black voters from Biden it's
disgusting Biden doesn't own those
voters sorry lady and Kanye West points
that at love that he says that he
believes quote Planned Parenthood's have
been placed inside cities by white
supremacists to do the devil's work yep
preach man absolutely that's the most
concise description of Planned
Parenthood that I have heard and their
political strategy of expansion in the
cities that I have ever heard from any
American politician now he's wrong on
China he kind of likes China so that's
bad and he
wants to spring people from prison
that's not good we know we don't like
that very much but you know he's right
on the democrats he says this is the
line of his - let's see if the
appointing is it 2020 or it's a 2024 but
God appoints the president if I win in
2020 and it was God's appointment if I
win in 2024 then that was God's
appointment what Kanye West is giving
here I know people think that sounds
kooky and crazy this is just a
description of what st. Paul tells us in
the scriptures and it's a description of
what Edmund Burke describes about
Providence that there is a an
overarching Providence to the world
great stuff I dig I like he was he says
that we need to pray we need to pray for
freedom it's all about God and we need
to stop doing things that make God mad
yeah man that's like my political
philosophy let's stop doing things that
make God mad and pray and pray for your
freedom bingo buddy man this guy's great
I can't wait for this guy to run for
president maybe like 2024 I don't
necessarily want him to take over Oh on
abortion I'm pro-life because I'm
following the word of the Bible mmm
oh good stuff this is great on being a
political novice he says I have to say
with all humility that is a man I don't
have all all of the pieces in the puzzle
he is humble it's one of these things
they say this with Trump - they say he's
a narcissist he's an egotist they say
this about Kanye but when you get past
the jokes there is a certain humility
here that is necessary especially if you
convert or revert to Christianity I mean
he goes on there's so many issues in
this whole I I strongly encourage you to
read this piece there's one bit - I want
to hit on just one last bit at the end
II he was asked about his policies and
he says I don't know if I would use the
word policy for the way I approach
things I don't have a policy when I went
to Nike and designed Yeezy and went to
Louis and designed of Louis Vuitton at
the same time it wasn't a policy was a
design we need to innovate the design to
be able to free the mind at the same
time yes that's right that's my view of
I know that's my view of politics though
we have been caught in this technocratic
egghead politics of just managing
spreadsheets what Edmund Burke might
have called the Sophos turfs
mists and calculators who he derided and
so Konya comes in he goes yeah I don't
want all those stupid egghead things
I've got a vision we got to pray for our
freedom got to do the right thing got to
stop killing babies I think it's great
it's terrific
I look forward to the future Kanye run
he even said in their egos I'm not sure
I don't have total clarity if it's 2020
or 2024 I if he runs in 2020 that's fine
I think he's probably missed the filing
deadline and you know I like Trump so
that wouldn't be but whatever I don't
care if he even if he runs that's fine
by me
all the libs think he's gonna steal
votes from Biden anyway so whatever
that's what well let them get very upset
about that for the few months but
regardless of whether or not Kanye
becomes president I'm not I'm not
willing to give my endorsement for
president Kanye yet but regardless of
whether or not he does what he says
about politics there has more
sophistication and political wisdom than
a hundred percent of Democrats in terms
of actually like a virtuous politics and
really more than probably 70% of
Republicans so I I congratulate Kanye
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description